Who is BT Kingsley?
Like, who is the
man of BT Kingsley?
BT Kingsley is a confident,
humble, original individual.
Original individual.
Original.
Like, I just be doing stuff.
Like I have all my random
phases, is to do collars up,
like a collared shirt.
And I have words on the back,
like yeah, I see you looking.
Like that.
You want to try something
if you want, yeah?
There's a Scarface.
There was two watches.
But anybody--
- Two watches?
- Two watches.
Just on the same wrist.
East coast, west coast.
That's how I was--
let me make sure
this is said on TV--
I was the first comedian to wear
lights on his shoes on stage.
The first.
Gary Owens, I saw you.
Nick Cannon, I saw you.
Lights?
I was the first.
Listen, I love--
Four years ago.
I love that that's
what pissed him off.
Nothing else.
Didn't give me no credit.
I love that
that's what pissed--
these motherfuckers stealing
the lights on the shoes, man.
Lights on the shoes.
Two watches.
So you're a trendsetter.
A trendsetter.
Trendsetter.
In my head, at least.
That's not in your
head. that's what you are.
Yeah, yeah.
That's what you're doing.
Talk to me about
this right here.
"Grown and Sexy."
This is a comedy night
with grown, serious--
I've seen very many
of these on the ground.
Very-- listen, hey, you guys,
when y'all take the flier?
Just say-- I'd rather
you say no then throw--
then throw it in the trash.
Throw it in your purse.
Throw it in the
back of your car.
Don't throw it on the
ground after you done
looked me in the face,
said you was coming.
You know what?
I'm gonna be-- I
ain't got nothing.
I ain't got nothing to do.
Fast-forward to 10 seconds
later and it's everywhere.
You ever picked one up and
chased the person down.
Absolutely.
Miss, I just saw
you drop the flier.
Mama, you know you
better than this.
It's time for you to
do what you do best, man.